- If you're not pursuing
your interests in life,
you're not realizing who you really are.
An entrepreneur could
be a business person,
could be an artist, could be a musician,
anybody who can have an idea
and turn it into reality.
Your business can always go away.
You can never get complacent.
'Cause I've had it all
taken away from me before.
I actually was pretty depressed
when I graduated from college.
I mean, I was literally
depressed for six months.
As soon as you are losing steam,
you've got to bring
people into your business
that can add a relentless passion to it.
And the light bulb went off
and it was literally
like I could see GoPros
mounted all over the
place and I got chills.
Why are you laughing?
(audience laughs)
My wife is laughing.
I made the Dean's List.
- He's an American businessman
and philanthropist.
He's the founder and CEO of GoPro.
He has an estimated net
worth of 770 million dollars.
He's Nick Woodman and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Number 10 is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for some special bonuses.
- We all have interests
and passions for a reason.
It's your inner voice telling you
what you should be doing with your life.
If you're not pursuing
your interests in life,
you're not realizing who you
really are and as a result,
you're not going to be
as happy as you can be.
- What does the word
entrepreneur mean to you?
- When somebody can take
an idea and make it real.
An entrepreneur could
be a business person,
could be an artist,
could be a musician.
Anybody who can have an idea
and turn it into reality.
- And how did you do that?
- I dedicated myself to it.
When I was 22-years-old,
I promised myself that
I would work my tail off
until the age of 30, at a minimum,
to succeed as an entrepreneur.
That was extremely important
because I had a lot of
failure along the way.
- Right, the first company
you started failed.
- Yeah, actually and
then there was a company
that I didn't even start that I failed at.
So I really had two failures
before I succeeded with GoPro.
- How do those failures drive you today?
Does it drive you?
- Well at the time
they scared me.
Failure isn't easy.
It wasn't like I thought,
oh, cool, I failed.
And success has taught me that one
of the most important things
an entrepreneur can have
is perseverance, a dedication,
a willingness to fail,
pick yourself up again
and give it another shot.
Because if you don't have that,
if you don't have that grit,
you're going to get run over.
- You started in 2002.
Let's talk about that
initiation of the dream.
How did that start and
how'd that come about?
- I'd started a business before that.
I raised four million bucks
of other people's money.
Started a web marketing company.
Went boom and bust with the
first .com boom and bust.
I knew I wanted to make
it as an entrepreneur
and start another
business but I had no idea
what I wanted to do.
So, for inspiration, I went surfing
and I planned a five-month surf trip
around Australia and Indonesia.
The inspiration came before I even left.
I wanted to capture photos
of myself and my friends
that I was going on the trip with
while we were surfing out in the water.
No camera existed that
allowed you to do that.
And so I set out to
develop this wrist harness
that I could put a single-use
disposable camera into
and surf with it.
I didn't even mean it
to be a business idea,
I just wanted to document
my experience on this trip.
As soon as I got it working well,
the light bulb went off
and I realized, oh my God!
There must be so many other surfers
in the world that want
something like this!
- So you started with
wrist straps, essentially.
But how do you go from wrist
straps, which are very simple,
to hardware and to actually
developing a camera?
- I wanted to use higher quality cameras
with my wrist strap to
capture higher quality photos
but every camera that I would
use with the strap surfing,
I would break the camera.
Because cameras weren't
designed to be used
during rigorous activities like surfing.
What I ended up doing
was I spent two years
going to trade shows,
the camera trade shows around the world,
to look for a camera that was close
to what I would want to design.
After a year and a half,
about a year, I found it.
Got the manufacturer to agree
to make the modifications
and begin building the cameras for me.
I actually did the deal without
ever meeting the actual company.
It was all e-mail.
I had one phone call where we could
barely understand each other
because of language barriers.
- Were they Chinese?
- They're in Shenzhen.
I wired my $5,000 for the tool to be,
the mold to be made
because it was actually
cheaper just to wire five grand
than to fly over there, meet them,
have a business trip and I just figured,
okay, we'll just go for it,
and they ended up being legitimate.
We were profitable from day one
because it was just me, one employee.
We just had no overhead
and rolled one good production run
into another and slowly scaled it.
The GoPro that everybody knows today
has been built on $265,000 of capital.
The Hero4 Session
is the first GoPro we've ever released
that didn't immediately take off.
It wasn't just that we're selling
against the strength of
HERO4 Black and Silver,
we also gaffed it and priced it wrong.
What I'm proud of is
that when we recognized
that we mis-priced GoPro,
and that it wasn't in the
interest of the customer
and the customer just
wasn't grooving on it,
we changed it.
It's not the last time we're
going to make moves like that,
a radical that are in favor
of the customer's experience
but if we can keep doing that,
we can keep differentiating
ourselves from how
a lot of other businesses operate
and that differentiation
is part of what makes
this company so special.
- How do you keep GoPro,
what you're famous for,
how do you keep it the best of the bunch?
- Well, having failed a couple times,
I recognize that your
business can always go away.
You can never get complacent
'cause I've had it all
taken away from me before.
It's important to wake up every morning
a little bit scared
that that might happen.
Never think that you've finally made it
- Does Shuame scare you?
Does Apple scare you?
- No, no, no.
Actually, competition
is a really good thing
because, yeah, of course
they scare you a little bit.
That's a good thing because it drives you.
It motivates you to put
more into your work,
to stay running and stay running hard
and that's something that we,
is alive and well at our culture,
and I think it's also important
to never let yourself
stop being a start-up.
Stop trying to re-invent yourself.
- You're getting new video all the time.
- All the time.
This is actually a video of a firefighter
rescuing and resuscitating a kitten.
- Yeah.
- And a video like that
would very easily go viral
all around the world.
I mean--
- Oh my, God, yeah.
- That's essentially a
commercial for GoPro.
- Essentially a commercial for GoPro.
(kitten meowing)
It's a marketer's dream
and it's all based off
of authenticity, right?
It's our customers
doing interesting things
around the world and they're so stoked
that they're able to finally self-document
these things that they like to do
and share it with people.
They're so stoked at how
good they look in the video
that when they share the video,
they often give us credit.
My GoPro ski trip.
My GoPro day at the park with my kids.
- You're the only CO that
I've ever interviewed
who's used the word stoked.
- Like five million times.
- Five million times, yes.
- Well, you know, you've got
to stay true to who you are
and I recognize that my approach to life
and now our company's approach to life
is what has made GoPro what it is
and so there's no reason to change that.
Everybody around me,
their parents were lawyers
or investment bankers or entrepreneurs.
They were all involved in business.
That actually didn't seem very
much fun to me growing up.
I thought that being an
adult's kind of a drag.
I actually was pretty depressed
when I graduated from college.
I mean, I was literally
depressed for like six months.
I woke up at one o'clock in the afternoon
and laid on a couch and
looked up at the ceiling
and was just like, dude,
what am I going to do?
So, with no inspiration, I
just decided, you know what?
The only thing I can
think of to do right now
that's going to make me
happy is if I go surfing.
So I planned a five month trip
around Australia and Indonesia
living out of a back pack
and a van at the time.
If I didn't follow my passion for surfing,
I would have never had the idea for GoPro.
You have got to be relentless.
One of the things that's
really benefited GoPro
is a healthy dose of fear
that you're going to get
taken out by somebody
and a healthy enthusiasm
for all of your great ideas
and being impatient as hell
to bring them to reality.
You know, having failed in business before
scared the hell out of me.
You know, I still wake up scared
that it's all going to go away.
- Right.
- Less scared than I used to be.
But it happens.
You can never say, ahh, we made it,
'cause that's when you get
hit by the competitive truck.
- Or a surf board.
You have to stay scared
and you also have to really,
really, really be relentless.
I always think about what
is the other company doing?
The other guy or gal,
what is their mindset
and how can we be more
aggressive than them?
How can we have a more aggressive roadmap,
development time line
to where we just absolutely
out-pace the competition?
Just wear them into the ground.
- Sure.
- I think that
that's been one of the
secrets to our success.
If you look at our development
and product release history,
from the HERO to the HERO2 to the HERO3
to the HERO3+ to the HERO4,
we've launched five new
cameras in the last 11 months.
We've made significant
advancements in our software,
all the while expanding
our global marketing,
growing into more than
40,000 retail stores
with our in-store retail merchandisers
in every single store.
Once we have those in
store, that's not enough.
Now, we need to grow footprints.
So we grow from two linear feet
of retail merchandising shelf space
to now 12 feet in big
stores like Best Buy.
Even our smaller format stores
are going from two to five
to some eight feet of linear.
You can never be done.
- So you've got to be relentless.
- You have to be relentless
and as soon as you are losing steam,
you've got to bring
people into your business
that can add a relentless passion to it.
If you don't feel like you're relentless,
chances are that you're competing
against somebody who is.
It's a race.
As long as you can bootstrap,
not at the sacrifice of
competitive advantage,
meaning not leaving yourself open,
not moving so slowly
that you leave yourself
to be eaten alive by your competitors.
Bootstrapping is a really powerful thing
because it allows you to be
totally devoted to your vision
and not have to deal with
the pressures of investors
to maybe realize milestones
and unrealistic timelines.
- Sure.
- Everybody has an idea over time
of what the business should be.
When the business is going
well, people leave you alone.
But I think maybe during
the formative period,
too many opinions could be disruptive.
I know it really helped GoPro
that we didn't have to
answer to anybody for years.
I think an example is when we,
as soon as we could afford
it, we bought a race car.
We went racing up at
Sonoma Raceway in Sonoma
and I learned how to drive a race car
and I became our chief R&D
developer for motor sport.
- When you're the founder,
you can do whatever you want to do.
- Yeah, but if we'd had
investors at that point,
they might have questioned, you know,
is this really a great
use of company proceeds?
In the end,
it led to one of the biggest ideas
that we ever had at GoPro,
which was to get the
camera off of the wrist
and make mounting accessories
so that you could use the camera,
mount the camera in any way imaginable.
The way that that happened was
I was in racing school
and they wanted to charge
me a bunch of money
to put a camera on the car.
And I thought, that's crazy.
I've got my wrist camera in my trunk
of my street car.
I went and got it,
strapped it to the roll bar,
and the light bulb went off.
It was literally like I could see GoPro's
mounted all over the place.
I got chills.
Until then,
we had been a little wrist
camera company plodding along.
Then that was a major hockey stick moment
for the company that was totally inspired
by climbing into a race car,
which is not what a board of directors
would normally think was a great idea.
I had a deal with my parents that
I got into Berkeley.
But I didn't get in here.
I was terrified of going to Berkeley
'cause it was so close to home.
(laughing)
My parents said, "You know what we said
"about you being able to pick
where you can go to school?"
"Yeah."
"As soon as you got into
Berkeley that choice went away.
"You're going there."
And I made a deal with them
that if I could get into UC San Diego,
would they let me go here?
This is where I wanted to go
and my motivation was it
was the best education
combined with the best surf.
I mean, just,
just being honest.
(laughing)
(audience applauding)
I wrote a very earnest letter of appeal.
Thank God, I got in!
The rest is the history that
we're continuing to write.
- What was the case that you made?
Do you remember?
- Yeah.
I promised that I would really buckle down
and put my head down.
(wife laughs)
Why are you laughing?
(audience laughs)
My wife is laughing.
I made the Dean's list.
(audience laughs)
In my freshman year, I think I made it.
I think I made it once or twice,
then kind of fell from there.
I promised to really devote myself
and make the most out of the education.
That I wasn't coming to party.
That I wasn't coming just to screw around.
That if UC San Diego would
give me the opportunity,
I would really make something
of myself at the school.
Thanks for taking a flyer on me.
The lesson there just is never give up.
Never give up.
'Cause if I went to Berkeley,
I don't think I would have had the...
That life is a winding path.
I just don't think I
would have had the same
interests and inspiration
there that led me, ultimately,
to my idea for GoPro.
- Thank you guys so much for watching!
I hope you enjoyed.
I made this video because
grnhy asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
you want me to profile next,
leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
Leave them in the comments and
I will join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
- A secret to GoPro's success,
people would wonder how did
you cash flow the business?
We learned early on that our
international distributors
would pay FOB Hong Kong, right?
They would pay when we would
ship to them from Hong Kong.
We would, in the day, get paid
by our international customers
before we even owed the factory the money.
We went against the grain,
and we built our
international business first
because they would pay up front.
We used the international revenue
to build the domestic
business which is the inverse
of what traditional business
logic would tell you,
which is build your domestic brand first
and then take it overseas.
I don't know that that really
works this day and age.
You'd pretty much have
to build globally quickly
or else somebody else'll do it for you.
Everything you need to succeed in life
is already out there.
You don't need a ton of money
and just go be scrappy and be dedicated,
and you can build your own GoPro.